well let us begin I'm assuming you can
all hear me thank you very much for
coming today I hope you came of your own
volition and we're not bullied into
actually being here my name is Alan
Caston I'm a professor of psychology in
child psychiatry here University and
apart from teaching and students I also
do research and I do research on
aggressive and anti-social behavior in
children this is a very serious problem
and I'll talk very little about that
today but I will say some things we've
been working on that problem for three
decades I started when I was two and we
have developed some treatments I have a
facility on campus called the Yale
parenting center where we see children
as families and we have developed some
treatments for these aggressive children
these are grassroots children are really
just as a preview they beat up peers and
siblings they beat up teachers and
parents they steal they set fires and
they do all sorts of things and it's
actually one of the most expensive
mental health problems in the United
States you hear of depression or
schizophrenia and this is a really very
serious problem so today I will talk
about bullying which is certainly a
subset of what we do and here are my
goals and I've asked to go at this time
slot because I need the time completely
it would be ending at 8 o'clock and
dinner we brought in probably about 7:30
I'm going to talk about bullying and
highlight several features and I've
tried to pull out those that I think
will be of special interest to you and
some of the latest findings bullying is
in the news and I will only cover that a
little bit that it's just it's just so
sad and so consider this first case of a
boy named ty 11 year old boy was bullies
and teased all the time teachers and
school personnel saw it said boys will
be boys and one day he fought back and
when he fought back he and the boy Heep
fought back at were both punished and
his punishment was to go home so his
mother who was a teacher at the school
took him home and then on her way back
to school ty shot himself and committed
suicide and the parents go
around the country trying to talk about
the seriousness of this and what schools
might do to protect a 17 year old boy
was tall and lean and by his peers he
was interested in nerdy things like
drama and music and he was teased
endlessly and he was pushed in his own
locker and people stuffed things in his
pockets and he said to his mom you know
I get picked on every day
and I've got a whole nine weeks left I
just can't do it anymore
and one of his peers said why don't you
just go home and shoot yourself no one
really miss you and he went home and he
shot himself and so there endless stream
of these kinds of stories and they're
really of course beyond the beyond
discussion that tragedy is ineffable but
there's another part that even adds to
it without the drama but with even the
greater prevalence and that is there are
all these stories of children who are
just suffering and rarely make the news
and you may have seen this one about a
young girl seven-year-old girl from
South Dakota and she was teased by
adults and her peers because her ears
stick out so much and so her mother
decided to have the operation flew the
child to New York to have the operation
to tape her ears back so she would no
longer be teased by this and the plastic
surgeon said oh no this is not cosmetic
surgery this is a wise move to to try to
avoid the endless teasing she'll
experience and lastly of this before we
get to the research there's a girl named
Amber and Amber has a fraternal twin
brother named Ryan and Amber's eight
years old she's heavy she has attention
deficit hyperactivity disorder and mood
disorder and she's miserable because
she's teased all of the time and she
doesn't want to go to school and so her
brother her brother this happened in
September last month and her brother
wrote the following letter to Santa
Claus Ryan her brother writes the
following letter to Santa Claus
I wanted a toy car and helicopter but I
don't want that anymore kids at school
are picking on Amber and it is not fair
I prayed that they will stop but God is
busy and needs your help this is the
level of desperation that there is in
there we could occupy a full
day of this and it is really endless
but the suicide clearly is the one that
captures the most amount of time and and
is a huge issue I do about three to four
hours of media work a week every week
and much of that is devoted to bullying
in the schools and what can be done
about it well let's get a little more
systematic and let's go through some of
the things I think you might find
interesting
bullying it has several components and
you're familiar with them but they're
relevant because they relate to other
topics that you wouldn't expect them to
be so it requires some aggressiveness
some power differential some
repetitiveness so it's not a one-shot
deal and negative impact and it's
distinguished from teasing which tends
not to have that kind of impact but of
course they blur together now when I was
young I know that's hard to imagine
Mother's has just been invented but when
I was young there was a great deal of
teasing and one teased about the other
person's mother and said horribly nasty
things and they were never taken
seriously and once someone was more
clever than you you just burst out
laughing and there was a lot of teasing
that wasn't bullying interspersed among
the bullying but it's blurs into
bullying partly because the apart from
intent the impact is what's important so
bullying is defined by the impact it has
on you and this follows sexual
harassment no matter what the intent of
someone does if the sexual harassment
makes an environment hostile it's
counted as sexual harassment legally and
that's the case with bullying too so the
negative impact all by itself is quite
is quite sufficient now there are many
forms and many types of bullying and the
physical of course verbal but the one
the one that's grabbing a great deal of
attention is cyberbullying and that's
bullying like none of us had in our past
and that is because it's very difficult
to detect by adults it's because you can
do this 24/7 and someone can bully you
without revealing their identity so
someone who's a little too shy to bully
you on the playground can easily do it
through a texting or through posting
some things on Facebook and these things
go viral as they say and so cyber
bullying is a really serious problem and
bullying can vary and but you can see
the different kinds of cyber bullying
that there are
and bully differ in their fossae and
this is surprising as you'll see in a
moment the usual suspects you might
expect so if someone race ethnicity and
culture particularly multiracial people
are really harassed religion is used
section sexual identity lesbian gay
sexual identity is really a strong basis
for for bullying disability any
exceptional exceptional characteristics
if you're thin if you're gifted if you
have a disability if you're obese it's
hard to find anyone who's really free of
bullying and the people who are are the
ones you'd expect this is someone who's
unusually popular or has a couple of
really good friends there aren't many
people who are immune from the effects
of bullying and as we go on you'll see
that even gets worse so to speak so how
bad is the problem well this is not a
time to to provide a tsunami of
statistics except to say that it's just
it's a heavy problem it goes across
years a school and it continues and
children say that of all the problems
they experience this is the greatest one
the most bothersome one in their lives
so it really is it really is a serious
problem in their lives and in the years
past we heard things like boys will be
boys an expression school personnel use
with the suicide case I started out with
and it's just teasing and name-calling
and of course the sticks and stones
which will return to a few times sticks
and stones may break my bones but names
will never hurt me
couldn't be further from the truth and
what we learned now is that the effects
are really pervasive that bullying just
doesn't make you feel this way or that
way it actually has impact on physical
health mental health and academic
performance and even more or I guess I
should say wait there's more and I'll
come back to that in a few minutes
and so there are many reasons it's
getting attention now bullying is
getting such attention many reasons and
they're all quite powerful there's
international concern there's legal
concern that course concern and each one
of these would be a wonderful source of
this
take us beyond the eight o'clock that I
planned so I've decided that I could
probably be most useful by elaborating
the scope of impact of bullying and I'll
spend a little bit more time on that so
there are a lot of reasons to be
focusing on bullying and so let me go
through what do we know and why some of
those reasons are so salient when this
whole work area started we thought there
were two groups bullies and victims
turns out there are four groups and some
subgroups that we need I need not occupy
ourselves with today and the four groups
are whilst talk about each one in turn
the the bully victims are people who
have do both they bully and they're
victimized and the bystanders we thought
were free from it all suffer as well and
I'll come back to that let me say a
little bit about the victims who are
these victims they these victims suffer
all kinds of ways low self-esteem
depression withdrawal anxiety and they
have a whole barrage of problems and
symptoms associated with this and this
is the most well studied group and they
really they are are suffering now let's
take a research interlude to present
some areas of psychology that are very
relevant to this and are actually
relevant to our own lives so let me
first begin by talking about a whole
area of research outside of bullying but
related that's referred to as ostracism
and this is ostracism as you can see
it's just being excluded or being
ignored and the immediate effects of
being of being ostracized are distress
and sadness and anger and so that's no
surprise and it decreases people's
feelings of belongingness and so forth
and we all have needs for being able to
control being part of the group and
these kind of get bashed when there's
any ostracism and there's an interesting
reactions and these makes sense so when
one is ostracized what it really does
first is to increase compliance
increased trying to get back in the
group people are nicer better they agree
more they do things to get closer to the
group and if that doesn't work they turn
the other way and now they become much
more aggressive and much more isolated
and the group isolates them even more
one of the interpretations of school
shootings is that these people have
reached this stage of ostracism and now
they're angry they're not just isolated
from others they can't get back into any
group and so now they do these sorts of
things these are all things that have
been really well studied and the the the
research kind of shows how these things
happen but it really does not tell you
the experience of what that's like so
but so let me say a little bit about
that when people report being ostracized
and the social pain of that they used
the word social pain in the research and
the use of the word social pain because
it lights up the pain from ostracism and
isolation lights up similar areas of the
brain as physical pain and even asked
people what's worse physical pain or
social pain they says social pain is
much worse how painful is it social pain
is like childbirth and back pain
so the social pain is not just some
little experience it's very serious
research hasn't been so great as
describing that experience but
Shakespeare has so if you'll forgive a
moment let me read a little bit from
Romeo and Juliet
to give you the experience that
Shakespeare has of being ostracized
as you recall Romeo has killed Tybalt
and the prince of Verona is going to
sentence him and there should be no
interesting thing here because the
penalty for killing someone is death in
Verona Friar Laurence is housing Romeo
and Friar Laurence comes to Romeo with
the great news the great news is that
instead of the death penalty the prince
has been merciful and instead of being
killed you will be banished
pardon I forgot I'm with a Yale audience
Harvard's it's okay to say that Yale you
have to be authentic you will be
banished it you recall that you'll be
banished it so so meanwhile the prince
the friar is happy because this is a
great news and Romeo tells us what it's
like to be ostracized forgive me there
is no world without Verona walls he says
but purgatory torture and Hell itself
hence banished
is banished from the world and the
world's the world's exits is death it's
torture its death mr. m-- tis torture
and not mercy and this quote shows two
things first of all my reading shows why
the drama department never invites me to
read anything and that's a little bit
annoying but the second point is the
main one and the second point is the
experience of being banished Shakespeare
has it down it's torture its death
miss termed that's pretty dramatic and
that follows with what we know from
people's report of that and from the
research on ostracism so ostracism is
very adaptive it keeps the group
together the person who's ostracized
they're suffering but the group is doing
better and so it's a natural process and
bullying is one form of ostracism let me
say a little bit about loneliness
research as well because this is very
different and very similar and this
applies to all of us potentially in the
room loneliness is a subjective state
and it relates to but doesn't have much
to do with being with other people you
could be married and have a big social
network but still be lonely and you
could be unmarried or have no partner
and still be not lonely so lonely is
subjective state very well studied and
subjective state makes a huge difference
as you will see in a moment the
subjective experience relates to all
kinds of things including physical
health people who are lonely are in poor
physical health and their risk of date
of death is as great as being a
cigarette smoker and greater than the
effects of not exercising and being
obese this is serious loneliness is not
just a subjective state children who are
stressed early in life by exposure to
violence harsh punishment they too are
stressed and they to show these earlier
these effects on the immune system I'll
say more about and poor physical health
also this year we've learned that stress
that's enduring such as bullying such as
loneliness such as ostracism affects
aging at the cellular level so we know
how this translates from stress in the
environment to cell change and if you
follow aging it changes the
telomeres but that's another topic so
let me summarize this ostracism and so
on what we find is that their mental and
physical health consequences but the
physical health consequences have been
the one that surprised us most of all
and these include a higher rates of
illness and earlier than expected death
in adulthood and these children who are
stressed died more in adulthood of
chronic respiratory disease cancer and
heart disease so this is not minor and
we know now a little bit how this
happens the enduring stress activates
the immune system in two ways it makes
it less able to control inflammation it
actually promotes inflammation and it
makes it less able to fight off
bacterial infection and as you may know
inflammation is implicated in many
diseases arthritis and diabetes
Parkinson's Alzheimer's and a host of
others so one wants to control that
sticks and stones will make it will
break my bones but names will never hurt
me don't believe it for a minute who are
the bullies well the bullies they've
been studied as well and we know a
little bit about their lives they are
less well monitored by their parents
monitoring by parents it turns out to be
very very critical when I was young
there was an expression on TV that was
very very prophetic not pathetic
prophetic and it's in its it's eight
o'clock or it's 10 o'clock do you know
where your children are and that's a
measure of monitoring where children are
not monitored they get into a great deal
of trouble especially teens and so
here's the case the bullies aren't
monitored usually very much they tend to
be impulsive in their temperament they
tend to be exposed to many models of
aggressive behavior could be videos
could be violence in the home and
they're more confident fearless and high
in self esteem and more socially astute
there's a cliche that they teach at
other universities that self-esteem is a
protection against mental problems
mental illness and so on and by and
large is not that way at all and here's
one of the reasons is that people who
are bullies have all kinds of
psychological problems but high
self-esteem is often associated with
bullying they're very popular initially
and as the school progresses now they
become isolated
and unpopular and what happens to
bullies well they have all sorts of
disruptive behaviors and long-term their
risk for criminal activity domestic
violence child abuse the thing that they
forced upon their own children so the
bullies have been studied and their
significant problems they have oh I went
too fast I apologize
so the third group we'll talk about it
is bully victims and these people are
victims and they also bully 30 to 50
percent of bullies also are victims and
this is the worst of all worlds they
essentially are the sum of all the
problems of bullies which is acting out
and disruptive behavior and fighting and
all the problems of victims
internalizing anxiety depression they
have it all and they also have a high
rate of other things so for example they
engage in self-injury self-injurious
behavior and pin pricking cutting these
things often help control anxiety and
60% of these bully victims have suicidal
thoughts so this is a serious group the
most serious group the group of the
poorest outcome I said that bullies
enjoy a period of high self esteem and
their their socially regarded well at
the beginning of all of this bullying
this doesn't happen for bullying victims
they're rejected and isolated from the
from the get-go and they have really
serious problems a group you'd never
think warrants any attention turns out
to be really a very interesting and
these are the people who are just there
they observe their bullying they're part
of the silence that a secrecy of
bullying since and they're they just
watch it and most bullying acts about 84
out 85% there's usually at least one
other person present seeing the bullying
act and that's a bystander and they have
some interesting problems of their own
they suffer anxiety they suffer guilt
they their attitude toward school is
very negative and they're are not doing
well because the bullying they see they
feel horrible about the person being
bullied that they didn't do anything
about it now not to go into a digression
too far but if you've run across the
term mirror new
and mirror networks you know that in the
brain there are these cells we have that
when you see someone going through
something motoric acts for example if I
pick up this water some brain cells in
my brain that make that happen are very
similar to the mirror neurons in your
brain that's actually picking this up in
some way as well and that's how learning
occurs in part a complex topic not for
us today for those who stay from the
8:00 to 9:00 session I'll gladly go into
it in more detail
watching bullying has very negative
effects on the bystanders now what makes
bystanders very interesting is that they
intervene once in a while that they
interrupt they don't do it often but
when they intervene when a bystander
says stop it they can stop bullying on
an average of ten seconds so they don't
jump in all the time but when they do
jump in the bullying stops within ten
seconds very interesting perhaps that
could be mobilized in some ways since
teachers don't see it usually and
parents know nothing of it usually the
bystander actually can do something so
bullying is a problem what can be done
well let me tell you what shouldn't be
done science never says should I take it
back let me tell you what is often done
but ineffective and let's begin with the
parents so the parents often say you
know stand up to a bully there's always
a bully in life and you must just stand
up to them and that will end it this
represents an unwitting parental
insensitivity and the reason is this the
bullies are really sophisticated they're
astute they're natural they choose
people who have some disability or
weakness or they choose people who have
no particular weakness but will never
fight back and boys have mastered that
and so to tell your child to fight isn't
going to do very much at all the bullies
are way ahead on who's going to do that
and who's not now at my clinic one of
the father said to his son one day being
fed up with this you go to school either
you beat up that bully or when you get
home I'm going to beat you up
and the poor boy he was he got
came home and he was beaten by his
father because he didn't stand up to the
bully it's a misunderstanding of
bullying you don't stand up to bullies
not because they're stronger because
they're too nuanced they've already
they've already kind of figured it out
by the time a parent learns about it
it's usually way too late to do anything
like stand up to a bully just ignore it
there's always a bully in life just walk
away and ignore it you can get away from
this play actually you can't
the bullies know there are dead spots on
at school there are opportunities in the
bathroom coming out of the bathroom and
bullies are so good at this that they
can pick it out also you never want to
have just ignored because we know that
children are suffering greatly they have
depression and anxiety they're not doing
well in school it's more somatic
complaints so don't let it go because
it's just not it's going to make your
child continue to suffer this one has a
sad and amusing part 2the what happens
this when the parent learns of this and
says I can let me take care of this and
so I've seen this scenario play out and
you'll be able to tell this in a minute
once I start so you call the other
parent and before the conversation
deteriorates it goes something like this
hi I'm Mary this is a this is Vivian and
and I wanted to call you that my son Tom
says that your son's really picking on
him sometimes even chugging shoving him
I don't know that's not that it doesn't
sound like my son he doesn't really show
people well he's shoving my son I'd like
you to maybe you could take care of it
you know how do I know your son isn't
shoving him Vivian I'm just telling you
in my mind you know you know you're
pretty aggressive by even making this
call I can see why my son would shove
your child maybe your child actually
needs it you know I can see why your
child's are bullied I know where you got
it from by I've seen that conversation
go downhill so many times it starts out
nice and then it just falls down very
very fast so trying the parent take care
of it there's not much that works there
the parent of the bully doesn't know
that bullying is going on very much just
as the parent of the victim rarely knows
the extent of the bullying let the
teacher take care of it there's a grain
of wisdom there but it's only a grain so
you go to the school you say teacher my
child's being bully can you take care of
it and the teacher kind of doesn't know
about it very much
isn't denial teacher usually don't see
it most of the bullying they don't see
at all and the teacher cannot do very
much so that doesn't tend to be very
helpful
these are wonderful things in in in
principal each one of these shows that
one's a caring parent and trying to do
something each one makes the parents
feel better because of taking action and
each one is likely to be ineffective and
so these are not things to do these are
things to probably avoid let's look at
what the teachers do why am i presenting
the ineffective ones because these are
the common ploys that are used I will
get to the effective ones very shortly
so the common teacher ploys involve two
strategies and the first one is related
to imparting information or knowledge
with the idea now they do things like
raise awareness or have things like
teachable moments there aren't teachable
moments it's a really unfortunate cliche
of our time explain why bullying is not
good and appeals to understanding
empathy and so on now if you consider
for a moment three domains we'd like to
change in people ones knowledge where
people know one's attitude how they feel
about something and one's behavior and
what the research shows unequivocally is
that knowledge is not that hard to
change an attitude actually isn't that
hard to change behavior is hard to
change and so these interventions aren't
going to change something you may not
believe me and none of this applies to
anyone in the room nothing I'm going to
say next applies to any of you
however some people have lived with
partners or spouses for many many years
and they've explained to that part in
her spouse something that's just
annoying somebody's little irritating
toothpaste toilet paper shoes in the
sink it doesn't matter and as you've
explained that you that people in the
other room have explained this to their
partners their partners know and it
doesn't change them and it's not
mal-intent it's a misunderstanding of
psychology knowledge does not make
people change very much if at all as a
matter of fact is there anyone on the
planet who thinks for a moment that
smoking is good for their health no you
would not say are you kidding me smoking
is bad
I'm
stop tomorrow it doesn't that's not the
intervention so knowledge it's not a
good basis for changing bullying at all
it's a it's known to be weak yes it can
have some impact but it's very weak as
interventions go and schools rely quite
heavily on it there was a study in the
news yesterday about schools that show
videos and that those videos that do not
just impart information they actually
increase the rate of bullying in the
schools so be careful what one does the
old adage that first do no harm is
really important but the second one be
don't spend your time on ineffective
interventions and schools often do that
the second category are more punitive
and these two have become cliches of our
time and they are things like there are
things like three strikes and you're out
and zero tolerance and tough love and
and children who bully are kicked out of
school all the time and that will do
really nothing as well the bullies will
come back it doesn't change the school
environment and it doesn't really help
very much and so something else is
really needed these are common as the
parental ones and they're not effective
well there are interventions that work
an effective interventions that are
school-based are now really quite
extensive and they do these things they
focus on these things they focus on the
school ethos the atmosphere the climate
and this atmosphere or climate refers to
the quality of the relationships whether
the discipline is viewed as fair school
spirit our academics important and these
things form climate schools with a good
climate reduce bullying you go in and
change the climate and show that
bullying goes down so it's not just a
correlation focus on the group you focus
on everyone in school not just bullies
and victims you focus on the the code of
silence for the bystanders have and you
bring everyone in on it and the
interventions multi-level you bring in
administrators you bring in teachers
students parents school bus drivers and
they're brought up on what's going on
students in class don't just here and
now as lectures they practice how to
respond when there is bullying and so
it's not just
talking about it it's actually focusing
on it setting up a standard and actually
practicing about it now something that's
really interesting is this last is this
last component
it looks like an effective bullying
intervention requires measurement that
is to say there's a way in which one has
to measure the effects bully bullying is
not picked up in the schools and you
need some way to assess whether the
intervention is working and how bad the
problem is and there are different ways
but the easiest one is the event that
has been used is to have a web-based
system so teachers parents children go
in and talk about bullying answer some
questions anonymously and this has been
done with thousands and thousands of
parents teachers actually going in and
giving a picture of what's going on what
kind of bullying occurs where the school
should respond a little bit better so
one needs to have some measurement
system in place if you know of a school
that has a bullying program and they're
not measuring the impact they're not
having a bullying program okay
now one of the most well known programs
was by a Norwegian chap named ole Weiss
and he developed us in the in the 1980s
and there were three suicides in Norway
that changed legislation in Norway and
Sweden and led to this bullying program
that used focus on the components I've
already mentioned and that had really a
very nice effect on bullying and reduced
bullying and victim's victimization 50%
changed all kinds of other behaviors
truancy theft fighting on campus and
improved social relations and school
performance and had a really broad
affects the program was developed
further and now there are many many
extensions it's been used all over the
world hundreds of schools in the United
States and a couple years ago Finland in
a demonstration with 150,000 students
similar results it's a very effective
intervention and it's been studied now
for a few decades and it can be very
effective in schools there are other
programs I've highlighted this because
it's the most well known and these to
focus on things like climate and of the
school and the entire peer group
situation so what can parents and
grandparents
I'm asked that often and there's a lot
there's a lot one can do first of all
the first thing to do is to look for
warning signs now these aren't helpful
in some way they're like the the the
signs of a cold or a flu they kind of
resemble the same thing little fever
feel uncomfortable and they're not
diagnostic originally when they come up
but these are the warning signs look for
the child to be more withdrawn than
usual more anxious not wanting to talk
about school sleep problems reporting
things are stolen replacing things that
are stolen negative attitude about even
going to school those things are
characteristic of being bullied trying
to foster a better dialogue with one's
children now this will seem
counterintuitive but the notion in
psychologists try to be an askable
askable parent now this is I'm a parent
and of course I have said what some of
you may have said well there's nothing
my child can't talk to me about well
that turns out to be absolutely false
for example pee teenagers who really
want to talk with their parents about
drugs and sex but they feel they can't
approach that at all so they go to their
peers but their parents are the first
choice and so how to get to be an
askable parent model talking about your
day start early talk about things at the
dinner table what was your day like just
talk about what happens don't
interrogate just talk about what happens
and I get that going that will make a
huge difference
now these doesn't have to be deep
conversations you don't have to say
things like you know he's really not
your father
no no just talk about your day and talk
about get everyone talking about their
day and more things will come out when
you do that quantity and quality time
are very important one is not a
substitute for the other but the nice
thing about quantity time is you have to
do anything
parallel play being together going on an
errand together try to have as many
routines and rituals as possible things
that you do regularly we go shopping
every Saturday morning we have this kind
of a dinner every Wednesday night it
doesn't matter what they are they don't
have any flashy
routines and rituals really have a great
effect on on family life
avoid parental interrogation this is
really a hard one because child comes
home from school teenager and then all
of a sudden it's verbal waterboarding so
how was your day do you have any
homework did everything go okay at
school no no no don't do any of that you
need decompression time child walks in
leave everybody alone child will come
out
start talking okay and now you this
these things can can kind of come out if
you find yourself that you've ever said
I want I want to know because I love you
if you've ever said that it means you've
pressed way too far okay and so just
gentle non interrogation will bring it
all out supervised computer time and
limited these video games now are not
just video games they're interactive
video games so you can play a game with
strangers and bullying goes on during
those video games so you've got the
negative impact to the aggressive games
themselves and your bullying going on
and so this unsupervised computer time
turns out to be the cave the situation
where cyber bullying goes on the most
and it's rather risky and dangerous
engage in problem-solving with your
child no problem solving has a very
technical meaning in psychology it has
to do is it one of the actually one of
the treatments we use with our children
at my clinic it has to do with
identifying situations so so someone
pushes you at the drinking fund what
could you do and if you do that what
would happen and you work all that out
verbally and then you actually practice
it on the spot with your parent or with
a teacher and that problem solving is a
very effective way of actually changing
behavior of bullying and even changing
behaviors of victim as well what parents
can do is contact the school but to
contact the school you need help if you
go by yourself it's not likely to be
effective you just likely to say that
you know what there's no real problem
it's a problem with just with just you
the school is lucky to deny it and the
denial of it is not necessarily
something that they're trying to hide so
for example recently I gave a talk at a
at a at a large school and they wanted
me to talk on bullying and so before the
talk the administrators wanted to meet
with me we chatted and they said
for coming and we wanted you here
because parents want to be informed and
we thought they'd like this topic but
it's actually not really relevant to our
school because there's no bullying but
still this is a worthwhile topic and
it's kind of hot so I'm glad you could
come and talk so I did my talk it was a
situation like this and then after my
talk I was swarmed all the parents there
was just a long line of parents who
wanted to talk and they only wanted to
talk about bullying at the school where
there was no bullying and I don't fault
the schools because I know now the
research is very clear you don't know
that bullying is going on most of the
time parents almost never know their
child being bullied and teachers really
know that as well sometimes they can see
in the classroom so the denial is not
just it's not just mischievous it could
be but there there really is genuine
ignorance sometimes in all of this so
and of course if you really run into a
problem contact the Yale parenting
center we do this every day let me say a
little bit about the context for
bullying that we're talking about
bullying but it's part of a broader
context in some very serious ways that
is to say there's a great deal of
violence we know in society already and
that violence goes way beyond bullying
and includes all of these things sexual
assault domestic violence and so on and
why mention these well because they're
related they're related in two ways
someone who perpetrates one kind of
violence is very likely at a different
point in life to perpetuate another kind
of violence and someone who is a victim
in one way at one point in life is very
lucky to be a victim in other places in
life so if you're abused child you're
likely to experience domestic violence
okay if you perpetrate bullying you're
likely to be engaging more engaging in
criminal behavior or beating your own
child or pulling the chain a little bit
too hard on that dog as you walk around
animal abuse is related to these other
kinds of abuse as well so bullying is a
marker it's a it's related to it's part
of a package
and bullying warrants attention all by
itself given the misery of everybody but
even if it didn't you'd want to jump in
and work on bullying because it's part
of that package it's not independent all
let me say a little bit about the Yale
parenting center where I work and what's
new there where we focus on this there
are three things let me mention about
this so I have the service I mentioned
and the service has been devoted two
years to working with aggressive and
violent children and we have developed
two effective treatments for that and
and we do that I mentioned I do a lot of
media work about six or seven years ago
a few things conspired that well you'll
appreciate one of them so one of the
marvelous features of an academic job is
that apart from the usual
characteristics you expect of a
professor yes I wear tweed coats yes I
stare at the floor at social gatherings
yes I mumble in a crowd and don't talk
to anybody but that is what I'm talking
about there are other professorial
characteristics that are wonderful one
is I really like to hide I do my
students religiously why they're not my
students they're collaborators so
there's not about getting away from them
but I hide to do my work I don't want to
be in the limelight I want to be hidden
so I'm gonna breakfast table one morning
six seven years ago and I'm hoping up
the Wall Street Journal it says child
mental health oh I knew child mental
health so what are they talking about
they're talking about my clinic with my
email address are you kidding me and you
know what is that all about I don't want
that I want I'm looking for non critical
acclaim I'm looking for non notoriety I
need that to get my work done and my
work is just amazingly stimulating so a
few things like that are happen at
Austin we're getting calls from all over
the world looking you can change fire
setting you can change people beating up
principals can you get my child eat
vegetables can you give my teenager
something so they won't roll their eyes
when I just say hi and you want to get
for me can you do anything for these
things well as any tennis player would
recognize for us
these are lobs getting your child eat
vegetables we can do that that's not a
really a big thing there's a wonderful
way to do that they're a bunch of ways
to that can you get my child toilet
trained the child's only four but I'm
worried that she won't be trained before
she goes to the prom the way this is
going now
yes we can get your child toiletry and
so we now we devote our service to kind
of the serious problems but also
challenges
parenting we can make all those things a
lot easier so one thing we do at the
place is to help parents with normal
everyday challenges and make life a
little easier and life is hard now many
parents have to get out of the home at a
certain time it's like a NASA rocket
lunch the alarm goes off at 7:00 I gotta
get to my job you get our job okay
you know euston two-child are you
dressed yet okay
Houston to chowder your teeth but can
you come downstairs as they're breakfast
ready grab them grab the lunch bag and
it's a launch and then then or your
child god forbid get sick you can't be
sick I have a meeting at 8:00 let's put
this mumps measles thing off for
tomorrow okay no no so so there's a lot
of pressure on families now and that
turns out pressure in the voice of a
parent makes children more oppositional
and so so anything you can do to help
with normal challenges can make a big
difference so we do that now and second
thing of what we do is that we have
gotten requests from all over the world
and so people want to come to New Haven
and some people some people come to New
Haven for a day or two but that isn't
what I want to do I don't want boutique
service that's the last thing I do nor
do I want it to be here at Yale even in
some ways so we now do online face to
face training of parents all over the
world parent in New Zealand these are
real places we work with New Zealand
Australia Luxembourg Peru Poland clicks
on the machine and says hi good morning
we're afternoon sometimes we have no
idea and and we have our our session
face to face encrypted laptop for laptop
and now that's much of what we do so
someone calls from Hawaii we can work
with them and we do do that another
thing we want the last thing I'll
mention about the chip is right we
really want to disseminate this we want
to get the word out and here's why
there's a mental health crisis in the
United States in the world and it
concludes many features it's an
interesting talk all by itself and that
is this most people in need of
psychological or psychiatric services in
this country do not receive them people
who need service do not receive them and
those who do receive them the vast
majority receive services that are
the best services they're not the
evidence-based services it's a crisis so
how does that affect what we're talking
about I want this information to get out
there and so we're trying to disseminate
this information and the irony of all
this of all ironies for decades there
was not much trouble getting money to do
the science government was keenly
interested in working on a problem that
had no treatment
so we developed to treatment and were
heavily funded for it now we want to
disseminate the benefits of that and
they're really no funds for that so it's
really difficult getting the word out
and so we're having some trouble we'd
love to be a center for bullying
research to get this out but there's no
real way to get that through the usual
funding well let me make some closing
comments don't get excited
closing for me means we're exactly three
hours left okay so let me make some
closing comments and the main messages
for today so bullying has impact
essentially on all the participants
there are bullies and victims we knew
that their ability victims well they
didn't really know that very well
but there are bystanders and all these
people suffer and when you have a
bullying program in the school the
bystanders do better in school their
attitude picks up and everyone likes
school better including the bystanders
and so it's not just getting rid of
bullying and victimization it's really
changing the environment in childhood
they're really untoward physical mental
health problems and academic performance
Goes Down and in adulthood it continues
that is to say these negative effects
now go into other areas for bullies and
victims criminal behavior financial
problems social relationship issues and
again physical and mental health
problems consider a somewhat odd
hypothetical situation let's say you had
the choice of choosing between six and
stones will break my bones or names will
never hurt me and you could choose for
your child which one the child would get
always choose the sticks and stones
never choose the names and the reason
sticks and stones do not prognosticate
negative things in the future and and
name
enduring stress from name-calling and
teasing really does it changes the
immune system those changes are enduring
sticks and stones you break a bone it's
sad it gets set and you're off again so
if you had a choice but you don't need
to make a choice they're really
wonderfully effective interventions
available right now and they've been
shown to work demonstrating ad nauseam
and the difficulty is we're having
trouble getting them to the people and
children who need them so the challenge
now is a little outside of science so
science has done wonderful things here
science helps us understand the nature
and the scope of the problem we know
that now science has totally give us the
the different effects on those victims
bully victims and bystanders we know
that now the short and long term
consequence is all done by really good
science and developing effective
interventions that - by really good
science so while there's much more to
understand we know enough now to really
have impact and we need more help in
getting both the word out and getting
these interventions it turns out this is
proving to be a very serious and
difficult challenge so getting effective
interventions looks like it's a small
part of what we need to do to be
effective here that's all I have to say
on bullying and I thank you so much for
being here and participating
you